all right bruce arians has not changed
his approach when it comes to
calling it like it is although he was a
little more subtle this time
with tom brady after brady had another
clunker his second clunker of the year
against the new orleans saints
here's brady from or excuse me here's
aryans from last night
when he was asked about the failure of
the offense
to get mike evans the ball
mike was open a bunch in that ball game
he just didn't
he didn't get targeted that's all he was
open it mike
was over now
there was more that looks like it was
from today and there was more from today
about aryans
being candid not ever coming out and
saying tom brady played poorly but
on the interception for the ball that
was intended for antonio brown
that was a poor throw right there was an
opportunity to get the ball antonio
brown on the first third down of the
game
and we went to gronk instead so
it doesn't hit in the face the way that
we've seen past
critiques from bruce arians but when you
weave it all together
arians doesn't think tom brady had a
very good game which
guess what he didn't have a very good
game but it's just
so odd to be in this situation where
number one tom brady has a really poor
game
and number two his coach is saying
anything other than on to cincinnati
about it shireen
yeah a little passive aggressive there
mike for sure
but you know he's right i went back and
watched there was a play
the first play for snap from scrimmage
because the saints kicked off of the
second quarter so it's 14 nothing at
that point
and mike evans just runs straight up the
field i mean he's wide open there's no
one within
20 or 30 yards of mike evans and
he never saw him evans is waving his
hand like
get me this ball and that certainly
could have changed the game
because of the buck score there it's 14
7.
maybe it's a game maybe it's a game at
that point maybe that's all the
buccaneers needed we'll never know
because then the saints went on to make
it 21 and then 28 and then 35 and
it was just an avalanche after that but
you know what i thought of mike when
when i was listening to brady
you remember the quote that lamar
jackson said well i think it was again
the chiefs are my kryptonite
i see the saints as tom brady's
kryptonite he has been terrible against
them in two games he's had the
most of his sacks have come in that game
most of his interceptions have come in
that game
he has just not been good this year in
the two games against the saints so you
do wonder if that's his kryptonite
and obviously they're probably going to
have to play the saints maybe in the
postseason they would have to hope the
saints
get knocked off by somebody else before
they meet him but
i don't know how the buccaneers beat the
saints the way the saints have taken
care of them the two games this season
and now the bucks are a game behind the
saints and essentially they're two games
behind
they have to make up over the balance of
the season because if they finish with
the same record the saints win
the division by virtue of the
head-to-head tiebreaker and
you know as we said earlier today and i
wrote something about it on pft green
bay had a great weekend
first of all they get their win taken
care of on thursday night they get on
the right track after being upset by the
vikings
they see the bears lose so the packers
own the nfc north this year
shocker then they see the seahawks lose
so the packers are tied with the
seahawks in the race for the number one
seed
and when the saints beat the bucks
that's great news for the packers
because the bucks have the
tiebreaker over the packers but the
packers have the tiebreaker over the
saints because the packers beat the
saints back in week three on sunday
night football
so it was a good weekend for the packers
a great weekend though
for the saints who have a pretty
manageable schedule the rest of the way
who may be in position for the fourth
straight year to have their hearts
ripped out in the playoffs
like they seem to always do they need to
avoid the vikings in the postseason if
they possibly can the vikings at three
and five
play at new orleans on christmas day
that'll be an opportunity for the saints
to ensure that they don't have to face
the vikings again when the playoffs
come around hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports